[Music]
[Applause]
but first I need one thing my sunglasses
into sparkling water and some carrot
sticks in a case for my scrunchie and a
bag for my scrunchie case you've
definitely come into your own as an
actor Debbie Ryan it wasn't that long
ago that you were a Disney Channel star
on Jesse but a lot has changed in the
last five years you've worked hard to
get a more mature reputation in your
acting career life hasn't always been
kind to you but you've got some good
times ahead so what have you been up to
these last five years it's been nearly
five years since Jesse ended and Debbie
Ryan has had a lot going on what will
she do next keep watching to find out
this is completely it does not you know
harassment and assault does not you know
choose one or the other
the first major project that Debbie Ryan
worked on after jesse was sing it sing
it is a series on youtube red that came
out in 2016 the show is a satire all
about music competition shows it
followed participants on a fictional
show called sing it that was a lot like
American Idol or The Voice the show's
premise was that the executive producer
was fired so a new producer came in he's
totally out of his league the show poked
fun at the over-the-top drama that comes
with a lot of reality TV shows they have
to balance petty squabbles and huge egos
Debbie played Holly Holliday who is one
of the judges really really so talented
Holly is a famous and egotistical singer
who is only on sing it to promote
herself the show only ran for ten
episodes but it was a lot of fun the
youtube series was even nominated for a
Streamy award debbie showed just how
versatile she is as an actor her role
was completely different from the
fun-loving nanny she played on Jesse
[Music]
it's not always easy to be a woman in
Hollywood unfortunately Debbie learned
this lesson early on in 2016 she
revealed that she had been in an abusive
relationship this was never a romantic
relationship she said that it was a
professional relationship but she
considered this person a close friend
for a while he was emotionally
manipulative he would demand her
passwords and see what she was doing on
her phone at one point his abuse turned
physical
that's when Debbie decided to ask for
help to get this person out of her life
when she confronted him a month after he
screamed and threw his phone at her then
he cried and told her he loved her
Debbie got out and she is using her
voice to help others it's hard and you
know once you walk away you have to have
a really good support team to stay away
she was part of the don't look away
domestic violence awareness campaign she
reminds people that any time someone
lays their hands on you they've crossed
the boundary were so happy that Debbie
was able to get out of the abusive
relationship before it got even worse
very interested in menswear and very
interested in a structure when you're
running around
in 2017 Debbie got her first starring
role in a movie that wasn't associated
with Disney
the film was Riptide Debbie plays the
lead character Cora who is a teen model
she's also the daughter of the head of a
major modeling firm and can never quite
live up to her mom's expectations a
scandalous video is leaked Sakura goes
to Australia to stay with her aunt until
things die down it's a feel-good family
bonding movie that received mixed
reviews yeah no one's ever really asked
for my opinion before if you're
wondering why you missed this movie it's
probably because it was more popular in
Australia than in other countries it
even got nominated for an award at the
Sydney Film Festival Debbie got to surf
for this movie which was pretty cool
this was again a totally different role
from the work she had done before she
was already working hard to get an image
that wasn't associated with the Disney
Channel your place is very boho chic
after Riptide Debbie went on to star and
more indie films in 2018 she acted
alongside Drake Bell and Kate Cassidy in
cover versions this was the first really
dark role that Debbie took on four
members of a band have a wild night of
partying that leads to illegal
activities and someone ends up losing
their life each of the band members tell
a different story to figure out what
happened she also acted in everyday this
film was about a teenager who falls in
love with the spirit that wakes up in a
new body every day whatever weird fake
role playing polyamorous type showed
you're into nowadays just don't involve
me then she teamed up with Katie Cassidy
again in the romantic comedy grace but
Debbie didn't just stick with indie
films she had a small role in life of
the party with Melissa McCarthy all of
the roles that Debbie played were
completely different she proved that she
could act in dark mysteries dramas and
comedies
she definitely beefed up her resume
during this time that I would do it I
would do it yeah
Debbie Ryan had a loyal fan base from
heart Disney Channel days but in 2018
she became a household name she got the
lead role on the Netflix series
insatiable Debbie plays patty Bledel she
was bullied in school for her weight for
years but then a freak accident injures
her jaw and forces her to be on a liquid
diet she loses a ton of weight and now
gets all sorts of attention she's bitter
and uses her newfound social status to
get revenge on the people who wronged
her she also trains to become a pageant
queen the show is a dark comedy and it
is a satire we sleep with him and he's
going to be so in love with me and I'm
going to protect him Debbie and the
show's directors try to point out that
everyone's way of thinking is flawed
nevertheless insatiable has gotten a lot
of criticism for the way it handles
weight and bullying debbie has handled
the criticism with grace she really
wants the show to point out flawed
beauty standards and what she describes
as society's brokeness despite all of
the critics the show is one of Netflix's
most popular original series debbie has
already had an amazing career but
there's a lot more happening in her life
than just work
debbie has been dating the drummer from
21 pilots on and off since 2013 but she
and Josh Dunn are definitely on right
now she even calls him her dude for life
in December of 2018 Debbie and Josh
announced that they were engaged they
had an adorable engagement photo shoot
in the tree house in New Zealand they
haven't set a date for the wedding yet
but Debbie did talk to the New York Post
about wedding planning truly shocked
yeah I mean I was ready and we've been
talking about it but I kind of was like
whatever she comes up with ideas for the
wedding and he tells her yes or no
she said she prefer to have a small
wedding but it sounds like other people
might want a bigger one
they've been playing this wedding for
over a year now we expect that we'll
hear more about it in the near future
they might even get married sometime in
2020 besides marriage what else is in
Debbie's future keep watching to find
out it's a man
and they told himself life isn't always
a fairy tale and sometimes even our
favorite stars make poor decisions
Debbie ended up making headlines back in
2016 she had been driving under the
influence and she got in a car wreck she
was driving her brand new Adi and made a
left turn she hit someone in a Mercedes
the cops gave her a field sobriety test
and her blood-alcohol limit was point 11
the person she hit claimed injury
because of this the cops arrested her
under charges of felony DUI they have to
make this arrests when someone is
injured in the wake of so much
horrifying tragedy and so much being
unearthed Debbie made her $100,000 bail
the charges were later dropped down to a
misdemeanor the injury was minor and her
blood level wasn't too far over the
legal limit they could have ended a lot
worse
Debbie released a public statement where
she apologized to her fans for her poor
judgment she recognized that she is a
role model for millions and that's not
how a role model should act she seems to
have learned her lesson debbie has
stayed out of legal trouble ever since
yeah yeah yeah I'm fine
debbie has become a huge success in
recent years it's hard to believe that
she got her acting start at age 13 she
can definitely credit Disney Channel
with giving her a head start into Fame
she worked hard and was a fan favorite
but these days her success reaches a
much wider audience debbie has a net
worth of over 4 million dollars she has
over 15 million followers on Instagram
and on Twitter she has 4 million debbie
has also started a podcast there you are
with debbie ryan is a great pod with
lots of big-name stars
Debbie interviews them about their lives
and their careers it's a great way to
get to know Debbie and other celebrities
there are currently 13 episodes to binge
and she'll be making even more how does
she find the time she is one busy lady
we'd say that debbie is doing pretty
well for herself these days it's one of
those things that like because it's so
hard it has to be worth it you have to
do it right
poor girl is a new film that just
dropped on Netflix the movie was written
by Alison Brie who also stars in it
Debbie plays the main character's
roommate Nicky horse girl is a deep dive
into mental health issues it's a drama
about a woman who's lucid dreams start
affecting her daily life debbie is
really proud to have been in this movie
she says it's a turning point in her
career after this she says there is no
going back she had to grow up a lot for
this movie it's more mature than her
previous roles she really admires Alison
Brie and has learned a lot from her in
this movie she helps the main character
navigate her mental break it's an
important film and Debbie takes it very
seriously
it looks like horse girl might be up for
some awards at the Sundance festival
we're excited to see this movie get more
recognition that now kind of showed me
how much I love the the kind of
production side of things
Debbie Ryan has had a lot of projects in
the last few years and she's not showing
any signs of slowing down now that she's
in the Netflix family her next film is
being produced by the streaming service
Knight teeth is about a young chauffeur
driver named Alfie Allen you'll
recognize him from Game of Thrones
he picks up two young women played by
debby ryan and lucy fry to take them to
different parties but they are not who
they seem we have to find him they drag
the chauffeur into a dangerous
underworld and he has to fight to
survive debbie is taking a whole new
direction with this film which is
currently filming there's also a chance
that we'll get a third season of
insatiable but we don't know for sure
either way we know that Debbie will keep
making awesome shows and movies we're
excited to see where the next stage of
her career takes her which Debbie Ryan
role is your favorite let us know in the
comments that's a wrap don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to the
things thanks for watching